the story of almost every mainline
legend of zelda game is pretty much the
same evil monster king tries to claim
godlike wish-granting artifact the
triforce in order to dominate the world
sword-wielding fairy child and magical
princess team up to stop evil monster
king for years that's all it seemed like
most zelda games were a lot of different
takes on the same idea the recent
release of the legend of zelda skyward
sword has got me thinking about the
series though it's actually a pretty
tragic and horrifying come along on a
journey with me as we consider how awful
it would be to live in hyrule and if you
have a good time don't forget to like
and subscribe so we can make more videos
like this one when skyward sword first
came out in 2011 it re-contextualized
the entire zelda series chronologically
it's the first zelda title the very
first time a monster king was defeated
by a sword kid and a magic princess
casual zelda fans might not have really
thought about it but that creates some
pretty huge implications for the world
that zelda games take place in it means
that each of the adventures in the zelda
series aren't just different takes on
the same apocalyptic monster king war
they're all separate uniquely horrifying
apocalyptic monster king wars skyward
sword recently remastered and
re-released on the nintendo switch
dictates once and for all that the zelda
games are a series of events on a
timeline or as it turns out
multiple timelines that said the series
isn't necessarily definitive about all
the events having happened exactly as
you play them the hyrule historia
nintendo's book that compiles the
complete legend of zelda timelines leans
into the legend part of the title to
suggest that these zelda stories might
have been altered through retelling over
the ages but it is a sure thing that in
the world in which hyrule exists the
broad strokes of the zelda games have
occurred over and over again across
millennia and that is incredibly
ridiculously
ludicrously sad the ending of skyward
sword sets up the tragedy that is hyrule
laying out why monster kings and sword
kids and magic princesses continue to
pop up in this world the game tells the
story of a war between demise some kind
of big bad demon and the good goddess
hylia demise wanted to rule the world
and gathered up all the demons into an
army to make that happen hylia wasn't
into it and gathered all the races of
the world to fight back except humans
who were getting so badly ravaged by
demons that hylia made them a magic sky
island to live on instead the goddess
eventually imprisoned demise who stayed
locked up for centuries until he breaks
loose during the course of skyward sword
the story you play is one in which
demise is beaten by highly as ace in the
hole sword kid i.e you and magic
princess but in these last moments
demise curses protagonists link in zelda
with his intense hatred dooming their
descendants to continually battle
against the revived monster king over
and over again until he is finally
victorious and that it appears is what
the legend of zelda series really is
demise coming back again and again
usually in the form of ganon the
franchise's perennial antagonist only to
be stopped by the descendants of link
and zelda or maybe the original
reincarnated link and zelda themselves
either interpretation is incredibly
bleak the hyrule historia isn't clear
which is the true case suggesting that
the names lincoln zelda could be passed
down through the generations because of
the stories of heroes who previously
bore them so in one read of the zelda
games link after link and zelda after
zelda are forced to give up their
regular lives and become heroes likely
because of some genetic debt passed down
throughout their lineage in an even more
horrific read the original sword kid and
the original magic princess are
continually reborn called into service
again and again to fight the magic
pigman bent on world domination let's
just think about that for a second link
and zelda come back to life whenever
ganon shows up and their fate is always
to stop him from ruining the world
lincoln zelda don't even get to relax
after they die because eventually
they'll pop back up in the bodies of
some hylian babies when they do they're
already in line to take on a resurrected
ganon a demonic sorcerer whose entire
deal is a destroying the world and b
killing link and zelda fun as the legend
of zelda games might be i get to put
them down when i feel like it if you're
link or zelda those endless wars would
be your whole existence for all eternity
that sounds conspicuously like hell to
be honest so yeah life is bad if you
happen to be link whether you're doomed
to serve as hyrule's hero for all
eternity or if you're just unlucky
enough to be born in the link family the
year ganon decides it's time to go
hunting for the triforce again and life
is especially bad if you're zelda for
the same reasons except you get the
added annoyance of spending a lot of
time during your reincarnated lives
kidnapped by maublins or trapped inside
a crystal or just like magically forced
to fall asleep but even if you're not
the unlucky person fated to play the
hero or the self-sacrificing princess in
this story you're still not off the hook
life is also bad if you just happen to
live in hyrule a kingdom that has been
the site of like
15 apocalypses more than once link has
used time travel to venture through time
into a world where ganon was successful
he deposed the hylian king destroyed the
hylian army and subjugated the hylian
people in ocarina of time you jumped
seven years into the future to find
castletown transformed into a scene from
dawn of the dead in wind waker the
entire kingdom is flooded by an ocean a
zelda version of water world where you
play kevin costner with a sword and a
talking boat in breath of the wild most
of the world is a devastated ruin except
for the big robots that wander around
and try to cook you where you stand with
devastating laser beams over and over
again hyrule sees random elites fight
over the triforce struggling to make it
grant their wishes this concerns only
roughly four people link zelda ganon and
sometimes the hylian king meanwhile
everyone else in hyrule is trying to
raise chickens or farm pumpkins or tell
fortunes going about their business
until these four dorks decide it's time
the world ended not only does their
eternal war have nothing to do with
anyone else who happens to live there
but their constant struggles seem to
have locked the world into a
never-ending medieval age even when the
people of hyrule's world manage to
create technology that might improve
their lives their civilization is
eventually annihilated and everyone goes
back to the drawing board of human
progress life is bad if you're link or
zelda but it's also bad if you live in
hyrule particularly because there's
nothing you can do about it one
particularly heartbreaking spin-off
zelda title cadence of hyrule
demonstrates this pretty clearly the
zelda crypt of the necrodancer crossover
episode centers on protagonists trying
to free hyrule from octavo a sorcerer
who lays a musical curse on the kingdom
over the course of the game playing as
linker zelda or a couple of other
characters you beat octavo's four
enchanted musical instruments and then
octavo himself it's only then that you
wind up traveling through time to the
future where you realize what octavo's
whole deal was this was a dude who
somehow learned about the whole endless
cycle of wars against gannon the
devastate the kingdom situation so he
decided to do something about it himself
he put lincoln zelda to sleep a
reasonable action given that so far they
failed to actually stop the thousands of
years of destruction and started
creating magical weapons of his own to
battle ganon octavo wasn't trying to
wreck hyrule or conquer it for himself
he was trying to save it once and for
all when you get to the future you find
that thanks to your interference the
evil monster king has you guessed it
succeeded in taking over the kingdom you
smashed octavo's magic warriors so there
was no one but octavo to try to take on
ganon and the sorcerer got thoroughly
rolled not only do you leave ganon to
rule hyrule for like two decades by
traveling in time to defeat him in the
future but you essentially set up octavo
to get killed in the process
what a hero but that's what the zelda
stories are like horrific for all
involved for link and zelda these games
are an endless generational cycle in
which neither person or their
descendants can ever escape their role
for everyone else in hyrule your options
are either to live a pastoral but boring
medieval life or to die screaming when
your generation's flavor of demon king
levels your kingdom again even people
who try to do something about this
endless cycle of apocalypses get smashed
under the boot heel of hylian fate
either by the resurrected demon guy or
by the reincarnated heroes
fun as the legend of zelda is and it's
really fun it's a series that also
imagines a living hell for all its many
characters we're in the 35th year of
zelda and with the release of the legend
of zelda skyward sword hd we're again
reminded of the thousands of years of
blood-soaked horror nintendo has wrought
on this fictional kingdom our only hope
is that the upcoming breath of the wild
2 might finally mark the end of the
eternal cycle of torment for the people
of hyrule the legendary hero the dutiful
princess and the endlessly furious demon
please nintendo just let link and zelda
die
stop torturing hyrule for our enjoyment
[Music]
you